la liste de debout la france et la liste
de l'upper qui sont deux listes
souverainistes qui défendent une
conception de l'europe des nations que
je partage totalement
je crois qu'elles ont naturellement
vocation les électeurs qui sont tournés
sur ces listes ont vocation à rejoindre
la liste normandie bleu marine au
deuxième tour je les vois pas voter pour
monsieur morin qui est un européiste
convaincu il assume d'ailleurs et c'est
tout à son honneur mais je vais aller
sur la question de l'europe les
positions sont extrêmement tranché
monsieur morin est un européiste
fédéralisme je suis pour l'europe des
nations
je crois que les électeurs de debout la
france son plus proche de ma conception
de l'union européenne que celle de
monsieur morin alors je